foreign
[Music]
let's see my mom has a huge pot belly
pig as a pet okay now here's a story I
want to read this is an actual important
story she rescued him from a farm he's
seven years old I believe
back when I was planning my wedding my
mom kept on trying to add things to my
wedding specifically for the pig
foreign
for example she wanted him to have his
own Buffet I turned all her ideas down
and told her the pig will not be
attending my wedding there's got to be a
fake story but I like it anyway even
after I told her I didn't want him at my
wedding she continued to try to get me
to plan my wedding around him she told
me that she needs him to be there
because it's her support animal he isn't
a registered support animal even though
he does bring her a big deal of comfort
in my husband's culture pigs are seen as
dirty animals and it would absolutely be
unfitting for me to have a pig at our
wedding especially because it would be
disrespectful to his family as opposed
to all the other cultures well that
would be totally normal right well my
mom decides to bring her pet pig to my
wedding anyway even after I told her not
to and she showed up late I could tell
my husband was highly upset with it but
saw me when I went to confront her
because he didn't want his new
mother-in-law to hate him was this thing
written by a pig because I can't even
hardly read it my sister-in-law ended up
getting scared because the pig rubbed up
against her which caused the pig to get
scared and run off and bump into some
expensive glass decorations which ended
up falling and breaking the future this
is not real this didn't happen come on I
think I saw this episode of King of
Queens I was beyond angry at my mom this
would have never happened if she didn't
bring her pig to my wedding so I yelled
at her to leave
this didn't happen at all but I hope it
did because you know what if it did if
it did happen then you are the a-hole
not your mom this would be amazing like
weddings are so boring and I understand
this is a a contradiction for me I'm a
big proponent of the holy sacrament of
matrimony I think people should get
married I think it's wonderful but it's
really boring too and uh it is just
excruciatingly boring what weddings are
by trying to keep the pig out this is
like a source of entertainment and this
is a wedding that people will remember
that's the other thing you want your
wedding to be memorable don't you and
most weddings are not memorable they're
forgotten for you you might talk about
them later our wedding was a magical day
no one else thought it was magical
everyone else was bored out of their
minds for most of it this is memorable
this is incredible I'm fully on board
with uh barn animals being included in
wedding parties
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
calling my brother a mama's boy and
refusing to apologize for ruining his
birthday okay my brother and his wife
live at my mom's house Mom tends to get
involved in their marriage constantly
and my brother lets her uh sister-in-law
always complains about mom steamrolling
her and her decisions and violating her
privacy when sister-in-law got pregnant
mom got worse she went out and bought a
whole nursery and put it in her room
despite sister-in-law having one in her
room the most recent conflict is about
mom pushing to be in the delivery room
and sister-in-law saying no my brother
not only is siding with Mom but he's
making promises to her to keep her happy
last week we were gathered at Mom's
house for our brother's birthday his
friends came and asked why sister-in-law
wasn't at dinner table my brother
nonchalant said that she was just being
a princess acting spoiled and immature
over everything I was shocked and hurt
on her behalf so I responded actually
she's probably just upset now that she
realizes that you're a grade A mama's
boy ready to do whatever mom says while
ignoring your wife's wishes brief
silence while his friend stared he
started arguing about how disrespectful
I was he told my husband uh to say
something and my husband just said don't
mind me I'm just a bystander
well your husband real Brave on your
husband's apart what's what's up with
the men in these fans this family here
dinner got awkward and my brother's
friends left early he went off on me
saying I embarrassed him before his
friends and ruined his birthday dinner I
decided to go home because he kept
yelling mom then called demanding I
apologize for the rude things I said at
dinner table but I refused I think first
of all you and your sister have similar
problems you both uh you both chose some
winners here so you're getting screamed
at and your husband just sitting there
don't mind me I'm just a bystander
coward no you're not the a-hole here I
mean I think you did the right thing the
first problem here is that your your
brother's a grown man throwing a
birthday party for himself
and you know how I feel about that as a
grown adult and you're throwing a
birthday party for yourself and then
crying because someone ruined it you
ruined my birthday
but are you five years old apparently so
at least emotionally and mentally to be
expected from an adult man who still
lives at home demands his mommy take his
side in arguments and look leaving all
that aside just a a quick tip here for
it should be pretty obvious but there
are many married couples don't seem to
understand this in a marriage
um you never complain about or insult
your spouse publicly in front of others
now you shouldn't insult your spouse at
all it's not a good thing to do but if
you're gonna have a heated disagreement
and there's gonna be and if there's
gonna be rude things said back and forth
and it shouldn't happen but it happens
sometimes in a marriage you never bring
other people in on that okay you never
do that it's never the right thing and
it's so you you have to it blows my mind
when I encounter people this is so
common like married couples they don't
understand first of all your loyalty
should be to your spouse first and
foremost that's the relationship that
should be the most meaningful to you in
the entire world that that's the
relationship that you that takes number
one priority is your relationship to
your spouse even above your kids your
relationship to your spouse is even more
important than your relationship to your
kids that comes first
because that's what your kids need your
kids need your the mom and dad to have a
good relationship so it's for their sake
also that you work on that relationship
first and then everything flows down
from there
[Music]
for some background my husband and I
have been married for a little over a
year we recently bought a nice house it
has a pool and a hot tub and one of the
things I've enjoyed is unwinding after a
long day my family has always been very
comfortable with nudity so I find it
really irritating and completely
unnecessary to be told to restrict some
perfectly harmless things such as
swimming and hot tubbing nude topless
sunbathing having to wear a bra whenever
guests are over nude grilling hot tubs
hippie houseboats now my husband's old
mom who is from A Different World my
husband's old mom does he have a new mom
there's something different about you
she's a southern lady who's super
prudish and very passive aggressive is
staying with us for a month my husband
wants me to stop sunbathing swimming hot
tubbing topless and dress up a little
bit more when having breakfast and
dinner and by dress up I think it means
like just dress it all he's not saying
dress up just dress put on anything any
kind of clothing at all we have guests
over please honey I flat out refused I
told her she's a guest in our house and
I won't be rude or inappropriate I'm not
gonna be rude inappropriate but I will
walk around nude am I the [ __ ] here
um are you the a-hole
yes you are
and you're also showing it off to
everybody in the house which is a good
indication that you are one that's a
rule of thumb if you're showing yourself
to people then you are one like that's I
think we could kind of take that but not
a bumper sticker that's worse to live by
a lot of entitled people and uh and it's
a common theme now maybe all these
entitled people don't walk around naked
in their house or maybe they do but
there's this this thing people do where
they expect every accommodation to be
made for them but if they are ever
expected to make any accommodation for
anybody else it's oppression so that's
the way she's living her life everyone's
accommodate to her but even being asked
to Simply put on clothing when my mother
is here she can't do that in conclusion
put some clothes on you freak that's my
message to this person and indeed to the
whole world a world which is very much
in need of it I think
I'm the winner
[Music]
[Music]